rebellions aren't just about ideals
they're about people
[Music]
hey there folks I want to talk about
Star Wars Andor which wrapped up uh last
week
I think if I've got my timing right yes
last week about a week and a half ago
now if you've been following over in the
break room of Geeks I've been doing
Episode by episode reviews and if you
have been following me there then
there's a fair amount of this is going
to be reiterative of things I've been
saying in those reviews
um but I still want to talk about it on
my bigger platform because
this was an amazing show
especially for me
I
have had a Sinking Feeling for a little
while that
Maybe Star Wars isn't for me anymore
that's kind of been going on to varying
degrees since well basically since after
Rogue one Rogue one was the last uh Star
Wars related thing that I really did
like
be unequivocally but
um everything since then has had varying
degrees of issues or I just haven't been
connecting with it
even stuff that I have liked hasn't
really stuck with me I did like well at
least the first half of book of Boba
Fett before it became Mandalorian two
and a half
um the Mandalorian I get the appeal of
it it doesn't connect with me I have not
been able to get into it the way that so
many other people are or even Obi-Wan
which I liked
didn't stick with me very much at all
hasn't La left any kind of lasting
impact it's was fine
I enjoyed it
and then I moved on
I was trying to get the sense that
what people who still love Star Wars are
there for and what they were getting
their desires as fans that were getting
fed were just not matching mine
and honestly like that's okay
people can like the same thing for
different reasons but what that can
sometimes mean is when you do something
that is fan pleasing it might not be
pleasing to all fans because not all
fans are in love with the exact same
aspects of a thing and so for me as
someone who has always had Star Wars in
my life to the point that I don't
actually remember watching these movies
for the first time I don't remember
doing that they've just always been
there the things that Star Wars likes to
focus on and that the fans most of them
tend to also focus on
aren't really where a lot of my
interests lie I suppose the simplest way
that I can put that is
when I was a little kid
and I would just play Star Wars I don't
mean like with action figures or what I
like just pretend pretend that I was in
that setting
I didn't imagine myself swinging a
lightsaber I imagine myself piloting an
X-Wing or hunkering down with a blaster
and and uh you know trying to trying to
escape
the the hordes but
I didn't think of myself as a Jedi
that's not to say that the force the
lightsabers
um the story of Luke or Vader whatever
don't hold appeal to me they do
but they're not so much of an appeal to
me that I want that more than I want
anything else I mean it was a year two
years ago when Star Wars Visions came
out and my big frustration with with
that was because I hadn't wanted to get
like the various animation styles of one
not spoiled for me ahead of time I
didn't realize that every single story
was going to center around
either a Sith or a Jedi or both and by
about halfway through that Anthology I
realize oh
every single one
despite how huge and massive and
sprawling these universe is we're gonna
have every single one of these be about
Jedi and Sith and some of them are even
good
but it didn't matter because like I'm
tired
I'm tired of that I'm burnt out and
again
I'm not the only one saying that and
some people have turned to things like
the Mandalorian but again even the
Mandalorian for me
while the actual titular character is
not a force user the story centers
around quite a few of them actually at
this point from season one it centers
around a force user and then later on as
stuff gets dropped in and over the
course of season two
it's a whole bunch of nostalgia stuff
that I'm not un nostalgic for but just
I'm like okay it wasn't quite scratching
the itch it was it's like when when
something when somebody's trying to
scratch a niche that you can't reach and
you're you want to go like just little
to the left
you're not quite there that's like the
Mandalorian for me
and so I was just starting to come to
terms of the fact that I
Maybe Star Wars isn't for me anymore
like I tried to watch bad batch
I bailed because it was far too
dependent on pre-existing knowledge of
things like uh the Clone Wars show and
Rebels which might be fine but I don't
have the energy to to do right now and
so much of what is planned for the
future Star Wars
I just look at the titles I'm like I uh
the thought of that is exhausting
I was excited about Andor though I was
pretty much only excited about and or
because I like Rogue one so much and
something that is in Rogue one that I
liked a lot and was what I wanted from
Andor and I got but I also got a lot
more than this but what that was was an
examination
of just people
the ground level living day to day not
out in the outskirts you know pulling
together a force as we go and we fight
and we go to destroy the Death Star and
we make plans in our pristine white rose
with our holographic displays no
ground level boots on the ground not
force users not people who will probably
even be remembered by name
what's it like for them
what's their contribution Rogue one gave
me that
and I wanted more of that from Andor
and it gave me that
so I was already very happy but it also
gave me something more
Andor gave me possibly
the best and most astute
dissection and presentation
of fascism that I think I've ever seen
because it's not just an aspect of
what's going on this is a story about
existing under a fascist system and
within a fascist system every single
character we see how this system affects
them
the good guys and the bad I don't mean
that in a oh well and it makes you feel
bad for the bad guys because they're
kind of victims too in a way some of
them are
but it gets this thing gets fascism so
well because
under fascism
nobody's happy
nobody
there's the people obviously the
oppressed very directly being harshly
dealt with having their their rights
restricted removed the workers who are
cogs in a machine but even the enforcers
even the people who keep the system
running and in theory are the
beneficiaries of that system
they're not happy
because they know they can lose it on a
dime
it can be taken from them as they take
it from other people
they have to watch their backs it
Harbors paranoia
amongst everybody you can't trust anyone
because you can be turned over to just
be ground up into the gears of the
system a fascist system
doesn't see people
it sees functions
if there is a function you can be
fulfilling be it through Labor
coerced or forced if it be a function
through planning and tactics whatever it
may be there is a function that the
system needs filled can you fulfill that
function we have use for you
but if you can no longer fill that
function or you are not or if you're
fulfilling it sub-optimally and somebody
else is better
doesn't matter
doesn't matter how loyal you've been to
the system it doesn't matter how much
you believe in the purported ideals of a
fascist system none of that matters
because you're not a person
you're a function
and if the system can't use you
it will dispose of you
and that is true of everyone at every
level within it and this shows that
this does such a good job of getting
down to the granular level because as I
said the rebellion and then the
resistance in the uh in the reboot not
reboot but the sequel trilogy
they have generally been shown
idealistically
Fighting For Freedom planning their
grand frontal assaults coming up with
with their strategies but the things
that actually have to be done and the
lives that have to be lost the lives
that have to be taken
in order for those plans to come to
fruition
that's what this deals with
now that's not to say Star Wars has
never tried to Grapple with these things
sometimes it's been very offhandedly
like all the way back in Return of the
Jedi with this line from mon mothma
this is
a bit of a throwaway line but it's an
attempt to acknowledge that
what we have that we're going to try and
use to bring about the peace has already
cost a lot of lives
we don't see them though
more recently you had some of the things
that the Last Jedi was doing now I made
a promise to myself that I would not let
this devolve into a slagging off of The
Last Jedi because I still don't like the
Last Jedi however I do need to point a
couple of things out
My overall feeling about the Last Jedi
at this point in time
is that I can understand
appreciate and even get behind a fair
amount of what it is doing or trying to
do on paper
I have issues both with some specific
execution but also I feel that the
context of that film was not the place
to explore these ideas
when it came to things like
deconstructing and pulling apart the
validity of the Jedi at all I don't have
a problem with that as a concept
but doing that as part of your main
number your main numbered Saga as the
second entry in a Trilogy Where the
first entry already did all this work
setting up that this is going to be a
joyful Nostalgia trip
that's maybe not the way in the place
and the time to try and do that
and it also tried to do something that
Andor spends basically its entire
runtime doing which is to highlight
that the resistance is not blameless
that there are wicked things that happen
and that the resistance is either aware
of and ignores or maybe even has decided
doesn't have a problem with or at the
very least isn't dealing with right now
because they've put their priorities
elsewhere
and there are bad people who are
empowered and enabled by what the
resistance either does or doesn't do
and that's not an invalid thing to bring
up at all
but it's kind of very telling that the
Kanto bite sequence with that takes
place I see very few people even people
who love the movie defending that scene
and those moments in their entirety
as far as the actual flow and structure
of the film goes when I see defenses of
Kanto bite
in The Last Jedi I generally see
defenses of what it's attempting to
illustrate and I can get behind that but
I don't think it works there
it works here
and the one last comparison I'll make
with the Last Jedi and then I'll try and
get off this topic
you take something like the very last
image of that film
of this kid just some kid we don't even
know his name
who appears
to have a gift with the force
and to end on that image an image that
implies the next hero can come from
anywhere
that's a great shot
in the wrong movie
had that been the last shot of the
trilogy
perfect no notes
but as the last shot of a milli of a
middle Trilogy that even before the
following entry was completely reworked
from the ground up and is an absolute
mess but even the earlier planes of what
it was going to be was never going to
pick up on that thread
that's not the place to make that point
it doesn't fit it doesn't flow
and even within the context of The Last
Jedi on its own taking the mess that is
the rise of Skywalker out of it it still
doesn't really work because
that gets a prop
the actual oppression
that is felt by people like him
is acknowledged and pointed to
but it's not explored
he doesn't have a voice that child nor
does anyone else like him they are
talked about
they are not given
the actual stage
to give their stories
and or gives them that
and I know I said it was done with Last
Jedi this is truly the last thing
curiosity
I ran a poll on both Twitter and on uh
the community tab for my own
uh YouTube channel now the results of
these polls are not some like conclusive
thing because obviously they're pulling
from a pool of people who either
subscribed to me here or follow me on
Twitter or were or the poll was brought
to their attention by people they know
who do follow me on Twitter or subscribe
to me here so like this is a this is a a
pool of likely like-minded people to
myself but I still found the results
interesting and what the question was
was an attempt to find out if people who
liked the Last Jedi also like Andor
because basically I'd had the thought
you know what's something I wouldn't
understand
if somebody did like the Last Jedi but
didn't like Andor I knew it was possible
to like Andor but not the Last Jedi as I
am an example of it but given that Andor
really felt like it was absolutely
nailing multiple not everything but
multiple things that the last shot I was
trying to do that
didn't work for me at least
I was curious like
is that an opinion held people like Last
Jedi is great but Andor is bad and it
turns out at least by those polls uh no
the exact numbers vary from the Twitter
and the uh YouTube poll but the overall
shape of the results is exactly the same
of the four options liking the Last Jedi
but not and or like and or but not the
Last Jedi liking both or liking neither
the one with the most votes was liking
both followed by liking Andor not liking
the Last Jedi and then at the very
bottom under even liking neither one was
liking the Last Jedi and didn't like
Andor so that felt very uh validating
in terms of of feeling like whether or
not you think Andor Does It Better Than
The Last Jedi
um at the very least it seems to hit a
similar nerve with a similar crowd in
terms of people are are liable to like
it if they also liked that and even a
decent amount of people like it who even
didn't like that so hey but
let's get back into Andor itself because
I've probably spent longer on the Last
Jedi that I'm into already
possibly a little misleading about Andor
it's the title Cassie and Andor is not
really the lead he is our mechanism and
our guide and our Connecting Point
through all the things that the show
shows us but he's not really the lead he
doesn't have all that much of an arc as
a character
we don't really get to have any
particularly deep examination of him he
doesn't do a ton of self-examining I
mean he's he's a survivalist he he has a
certain sense of Honor
he has a certain sense of right and
wrong but he's going to do what will get
him to survive the situation he's in
that's kind of just fundamentally who he
is and that never really changes
but that's fine
because it is through him
that we connect all the pieces it is
through him
that we get to see
the workers at a ground level who have
been trying to stay out
of the conflict of those resisting
the fascist Empire it's how we get our
Taste of the building rebellion and the
people at the ground level who are
involved in that it's through and or
that we get our Taste of the people who
are running that Rebellion or trying to
and that's another thing that this gets
really really well about not only
fascism
but about the layers involved in trying
to fight it
because you do need people at the ground
level who are willing to fight
and who have to be doing it honestly
probably just for their own Survival
in many cases in the cases of something
like the prisoners they literally have
nothing to lose other than their lives
but that also means they have everything
to lose and so you need people
who have just had it
and will take whatever comes at them
if it means they stand up and say we're
not putting up with this anymore
but you also need people who will
channel that
funnel that organize that and that's
where you get characters like Lutheran
and mon mothma
and Lutheran in particular I find
fascinating
because Lutheran is
not a million miles away from the
fascist system he's trying to take down
he does not see
the people that he is moving about and
helping to command to get these
resources raid this place recruit this
person he doesn't really see them as
people because if he saw them as people
he would not be able to do what he does
he would not be able to order the
commands that he makes and he would not
be able to keep an eye on the greater
good if he was worried about these
people as people I've condemned to use
the tools of my enemy
to defeat them but the show also
understands that that does not make him
the same as the Empire if only for
difference of motive because there is a
similarity
in terms of what he does but why he does
it is very different and that matters
because the Empire sees people as
functions and as cogs and as not people
because that is how it maintains its own
power that is how it holds on to its
strength or the illusion of its strength
that is how it maintains the death grip
that it has on everybody Lutheran does
view those under his command for lack of
a better way to put it in a fairly
similar way
but with the goal of breaking that
that Lutheran like wants power
it doesn't really seem or at least at
this point has not been laid out that he
wants to actually Ascend to power he
doesn't want to be the one in charge he
just wants to break
what is currently in place
and
he is willing to use tactics and
approaches
that would not be
um a million miles away from being at
home within the empire in order to do it
but again that does not make him
equivocal to the Empire
because what his goal is and what he's
trying to accomplish is fundamentally
opposed to what the Empire is doing
that's a tough balance to strike
to show the callousness
of someone on the quote-unquote right
side of a conflict
but to not have it be unequivocal oh
both sides cause never for an instant
ever
does this show present the growing
Rebellion or any of the people in it as
equivocal even when they have a similar
Outlook and approach like Lutheran does
he's still not the same and the show
never presents it as if he is this is
part of what fascism does
it doesn't just oppress
it twists
it twists those within its workings
to view all others the way that the
system desires them to be
as functions as resources not as people
and even those who wish to fight against
it
it twists them
because you cannot fight
something like this with ideals alone
you have to be able and willing to do
what it takes to dismantle this and that
will mean doing things that on paper in
terms of ideals principles
are bad things but even as someone like
Lutheran says this is for the greater
good
he doesn't let himself off the hook
and the show doesn't let him off the
hook
it doesn't pretend that there isn't an
understandable reason for why he is
making these decisions
but it also doesn't pretend that just
because he's doing it for the right
reasons doesn't make these actions okay
or to pull a quote from one of my
favorite doctors from Doctor Who
it's never found blue stuff up
sometimes sadly it's the only solution
yeah objectively it's not okay to blow
things up
but sometimes you have to and that
doesn't suddenly mean that blowing
things up is a righteous Act
but maybe it's become a necessary one it
matters so much to me
that this show understands
the damage and How Deeply rooted and
far-reaching the damage of fascism and
power is
and when characters sometimes in one
case posthumously point out this came
about and we didn't do more to stop it
because
we said well we have each other
we took that money and ignored them we
kept their engines churning and the
moment they pulled away we forgot them
because we had each other
well hold on to what we have and we'll
get through this well this thing that we
have allowed to get into place is not
going away we receive it
I've been sleeping
I've been turning away from the truth I
want it not to face it's here and it's
not visiting anymore and it will take
the very thing that we were taking
comfort in from us
if we don't fight back well at this
point even if we do but this has to be
opposed
and it will be done at a cost
a great cause a continually paid cost
but it has to happen
this is one of the
purest pieces of anti-fascist
entertainment that I've seen
and it is done methodically
and thoughtfully
most things of entertainment that you
could point to is anti-fascist have a
tendency to not have the time or the
space or the breathing room to really
examine what fascism looks like Beyond
you know the iconography of things like
the Nazis
you can evoke that easily enough and
it'll do in a pinch if all you've got is
two hours for a movie
but when you've got 12 hours for a
series
you can really really get in down in the
dirt dig in to these systems show what
they do to people
also show
their weaknesses
because as I said even the people within
the system don't actually benefit from
the system
and maybe it doesn't take that much
pushing
to get them to flee
to bail
to turn on each other
to reveal that they are not as strong as
they project themselves to be because
fascism holding on to power is not about
strength it is about the projection of
strength
they have to look like they are always
in control but sometimes in trying to do
so
they tip their hands
or as cassium puts it
but we're lost in panic so you have
something like the prison
that has barely any guards
nobody is watching
nobody is listening to the prisoners
because they don't have to
if the prisoners believe that there is
no way for them to escape then they
won't try
but that illusion is not real power
and the illusion
of control
is just that
and illusions
are a lot easier to break
but of course it's not an illusion with
nothing there is actual
violence I was going to say power maybe
not really power but there is certainly
violence behind an attempt to hold on to
that power
and that violence will be enacted
this show
understands that balance between yes
this is terrible
this is oppressive
this must be fought
but it's not Unstoppable
it will tell you that it is
it will tell you
that you can't fight it
because it needs you to think that but
it wouldn't need you to think that it
wouldn't need to tell you that if it was
actually
Unstoppable this thing understands
fascism so well
and it shows
how
everyone
can in some way
push back against it
people with influence with money
with nothing the power holds
when no one acts
and it weakens for every single person
who does
this is a phenomenal show
and it's
Journey
through the different aspects
of an oppressed Society
and the people within it
who are broken
fighting
[Music]
and working within that system
is so
dense
the more I think about this show or any
given episode of the show The More I
Love It
and I haven't felt that way about Star
Wars for a long time I'm not going to
say that this reignites my passion for
all things Star Wars this is a very
specific sliver of Star Wars that I
didn't think I had any right to hope I
get
but I have it now
and
I'm so happy to have it
and I don't need all Star Wars to look
like this
I don't need all Star Wars to be this
gray
frankly at times depressing look
at how awful everything is
although to be clear there are wonderful
moments of Hope and catharsis in this
show as well but like this is not a tone
I want all Star Wars to be
but this is why this was the perfect
venue for this
remember how I said some of what the
Last Jedi did didn't work for me because
that felt like the wrong place to do it
this is the right place
side project not a main part of the Saga
not going this is definitive Star Wars
but going hey
we're going to take this thing off to
the side you don't have to take it in
that's up to you it's optional
but we're gonna dive deep
into stuff that we don't have the time
to do in the main
bombastic nostalgic
spectacle Saga
this is what I have wanted these Side
Stories these side projects to be I
don't want a show that captures what the
movies does or tries to I have the
movies for that
I want this
and now I have it
and maybe it's not for everybody because
again
what people love about something isn't
going to be the same across the board so
maybe what you love about Star Wars
means and or doesn't hold a lot of
interest for you and that's fine
but speaking as someone who felt like
their love and their focuses as a fan
were just going to be ignored
this was a this was such a treat
and I'm so excited for the second season
Andor
a bit of a gushing
uh review not even but
I really did like it what what were your
thoughts on this whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon is what pays the
bills around here
uh anima you can help is of great
assistance even if you can't
like share subscribe or help me out
but what I really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin but fulla Tarak the thing that
goes doink in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi leotha Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shayla gourlay Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]